- [Gary] Nothing like JFK.
Love it.
Excuse me.
JFK.
New York City.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
It's been a long week.
Time to take a good, hot shower.
But I'll say this.
It's gonna be a short Friday
episode but I'll say this.
Because of all the travel it
gave me an opportunity to get in
to the comments, dig in.
Spend time with you guys.
And I feel incredibly sharp and
ready for next week's content
strategy execution topics.
And I just am stunned that we're
10 years in and people don't
realize the number (mumbles),
the number one,
couldn't even say it.
The number one way to win in
this game of personal brand,
brands that are marketing
and building and selling and
engaging and navigating
through the social mobile web
is to read every comment,
is to answer everybody.
Have you answered everybody's
comments on your Instagram?
I said a lot of times
in Ireland and Belgium,
don't listen to what
I say, watch what I do.
Not doing 60 Second Club
for kicks and giggles.
I'm not aggressively
using stories on
Instagram for swipe ups for fun.
I haven't reengaged hard
core on Snapchat this week
'cause it's good for my health.
These are fucking strategies so
I guess what I'm saying is
I'm really enjoying
getting to know all of you.
The things you react to.
All those little hearts
I'm giving you on Instagram,
all those replies
I'm giving you on Twitter,
all the stuff, I'm listening.
I'm listening.
Everybody thinks I'm talking.
("Eleven:11" by Pell)